whenever they
[Music]
the landing grounds
to fight in the fields and Industry
never surrender
in the last lecture we talked about the
role of air power in world war two but
now let's look at the use of ships and
navies and the striking thing that at
the beginning that that we notice is
that they're very similar in the sense
that the war will be decided on the
ground not in the air and not on water
but maybe the ground war will be
determined by what happens in the air or
on water and the same concepts reappear
that of supremacy and superiority and
then parody in other words if you put
assets labor and capital and personnel
out at sea and the other side has a navy
or warships that are roughly comparable
then you've wasted your investment they
will fight against each other but they
will not alter the calculus on land if
your ships are more plentiful or they're
better designed or they're the right
ships or they're better commanded and
they're better operated and you can
destroy a great number of the enemy's
naval assets then you achieve naval
superiority which means you can operate
against land forces without too much
worry of enemy opposition if you achieve
naval supremacy then you're free to do
whatever you want globally on the seas
you can import export food you can land
troops wherever you want them you can
bombard the shore from naval batteries
so that was the point throughout the
history of naval warfare is to achieve
naval supremacy so you can use those
assets on water to enhance the war on
the ground which will ultimately be the
arbiter of who wins and who loses when
the war broke out in 1939 again there
was the Continental power of Italy and
Germany and their Eastern European
allies along with the collusion of the
Soviet Union under the Molotov
Ribbentrop pact but the United States
was 3,000 miles distant in the Atlantic
from the
theatres in Europe and even more so in
the Pacific from what was going on in
Southeast Asia and China and so the
question was if you're an axis power and
you have declared war on the United
States as happened in December of 1941
how do you reach it if you don't have
four-engine bombers that can bomb the
mainland do you have a mechanism to send
a ship over that can either what bombard
the shore well that could at best that
could be 20 miles but do you have an
aircraft carrier that can send bombers
they hit Detroit again the answer is no
so in the case of relative naval
strength the war breaks out with some
pretty stark realities number one Italy
which has the largest Navy after the
collapse of the French Navy in the
Mediterranean it has the largest Navy in
the Mediterranean does not build a
single aircraft carrier Germany does not
build a single aircraft carrier it's
almost analogous to their failure to
achieve a four-engine bomber program in
other words they do not have a mechanism
to transmit naval power in a way that
would hurt the mainland and the
industrial center of their enemies in
the United States or Russia or along
Russian Russia's coast or Great Britain
in contrast the United States starts the
war with six aircraft carriers fleet
carriers that is larger or almost as
large as 20,000 tons of displacement and
above and Britain has about seven and
more importantly there's been a
revolutionary change in thinking about
naval power before the war starts that
will see the United States create orders
for more aircraft carriers than all of
the navies combined in World War two and
Britain has the same change of thinking
at least on the drawing boards when the
war breaks out now the axis have some
advantages unlike air power they haven't
quite made the same catastrophic
mistakes they are captive
to interwar naval thinking which puts a
great premise E on the battleship
according to the naval theories of the
great strategist Alfred Mahan the idea
was that if you could destroy the
enemy's warships at sea then like a wolf
among sheep you could send a dreadnought
or a battleship through an enemy convoy
and just be unstoppable in your
destruction you could just fire salvo
after salvo and nothing could stop you
if you achieved naval superiority so how
did you obtain naval superiority and the
answer was you build a battleship and by
1939 they were pretty much standard in
size because of arms limitation treaties
in Washington and London they were about
35,000 tons of displacement Oh 800 feet
long somewhere around 2,000 to 2,500 men
operated these ships and they had guns
maybe nine maybe six maybe somewhere in
between of either 14-inch guns or
16-inch guns and that meant they could
fire a projectile about the size of a
Volkswagen 28 at 22 miles so the point
of a battleship was to send your fleet
surrounded by smaller heavy cruisers
light cruisers and destroyers find the
enemy and according to the theories of
Mahan destroy the enemy's fleet Mahan
was very influential because in the
Russian Japanese war in 1905 at the
Battle of Tsushima the Japanese Navy had
destroyed Russians battleships and
cruisers and thereby was free to do
whatever it wanted to the Russian
merchant fleet which was followed by an
armistice and of de facto surrender in
the part of the Tsar at the Battle of
Jutland and World War one the German
fleet actually went out in hopes that it
could nullify
the British really did pretty well it
inflicted more damage and it suffered
but it did not destroy British naval
superiority and therefore Britain's was
still able to conduct a very effective
blockade but the thinking still was if
you want to obtain superiority and
therefore export and import or blockade
an enemy you needed better battleships
you need more of them and you needed
bigger and bigger calibers this
manifested itself unfortunately in the
axis idea with we're going to put a lot
of investments we can instead of
building 20 destroyers we will build a
45,000 ton Bismarck and its sister ship
the Tirpitz and you could build 20
destroyers for this for the amount of
money that went into the Bismarck or the
Tirpitz or in the case of Japan we we
can't build as many ships of the United
States but we'll build the Musashi and
the Yamamoto which are the largest
warships in the world at 70,000 tons and
they have as no other battleship before
or since has been able to pull off they
had 18-inch guns so think of that the
rationale the Yamato and Musashi will
sit off 24 miles from an American
battleship fleet and vomit at will and
their 16-inch guns will not be able to
hit ours they'll follow a mile or two
short and then when the war broke out
people were even envisioning a super
battleship Klaus in all of the
belligerent navies that would have guns
of 20 inches that could fire maybe 26
miles and beat an 18 inch battery of the
opponent well you can see where this is
going
it means that certain navies are not
being flexible and they're not being
diversified they're putting all of their
scarce resources or at least to many of
their scarce resources into bigger and
fewer battleships but the answer arises
immediately well a battleship has a
killing radius of about 20 or so miles
but if you have an asset like an
aircraft carrier
and it has 90 fighters dive bombers
torpedo planes and they can fly 2 to 500
miles and turn around and land on that
carrier then you can increase your
radius of lethality tenfold over a
battleship
but because battleships were so majestic
they cut such a an awesome spectacle on
the sea and they were so invested in by
the naval hierarchies people didn't
catch on when the war broke out to that
reality and so the history of naval
power in 1939 to 1945 is simply a
question of which Navy will wise up and
stop investing in battleships and divert
that investment to aircraft carriers
submarines destroyers that can attack
merchant ships far more efficiently or
they can destroy other battleships in
the case of carriers with air power and
the answer was that Italy and Germany
lost that war they did not build an
aircraft carriers I said but their
effort to build u-boats as successful in
the case of Germany it was it was too
little or too late when the war broke
out for all the vaunted u-boat
reputation in Germany gained from World
War one it still only had about 60
u-boats that were operable in the
Atlantic or the Mediterranean so what
was going to happen in World War two was
which side would increase their number
of carriers Japan started a war with
seven fleet carriers the United States
and the Pacific had only three the
Saratoga the Lexington and the
enterprise however we were able to bring
the Hornet and the wasp aware that made
five and then we put on order 27x
Essex carriers each one of which were
better than any aircraft carrier in the
world along with orders for additional
additional e battleships cruisers
light cruisers destroyers and submarines
that in their totality would be by 1944
larger than the German the Italian the
Japanese the Russian and the British
Navy put together and so in the way of
thinking among the accessed strategists
it was we started this war in the case
of Germany without a very good Navy we
invested heavily in battleships and
battle cruisers we don't have enough
u-boats and yet we're subject to a
blockade and that's going to affect our
strategy we can go into Russia perhaps
and get missing or or food or fuel that
we can't import but if we're really
gonna damage Britain and we can't bomb
them because we don't have air supremacy
maybe we needed a Navy to stop
importation to Britain through the Suez
Canal and Gibraltar and and so they
looked toward Italy and in the case of
America they look toward Japan and one
of the reasons that Hitler was so eager
to court a relatively weak Italy and a
relatively unknown Japan was he was so
sensitive to the inability of the German
Navy to even achieve parity against the
British Navy and therefore it had no
ability to stop Britain that he
magnified the importance of the Italian
Navy and the attack in the Mediterranean
and the Japanese Navy in the Pacific
Germany tried to square the circle of
not having aircraft carriers and
realising its mistake in the 1930s of
investing too heavily in battleships by
going on a breakneck pace to create
u-boats and the idea was we've got to
get not just 100 or 200 or 300 we've got
to get a thousand u-boats in at sea and
remember they could go down to about 300
feet and they had very successful air
compression compressed air torpedoes and
they could attack in wolf packs they
were pretty adept at initially breaking
radiation
able codes and the idea was that they
could destroy enough convoys coming from
the British Empire specifically Canada
and Australia South Africa to feed and
fuel Britain that it would give up even
though they could not vomit into
submission and one of the reasons that
Hitler so unwisely declared war in the
United States and December 11th was his
u-boats commanders were telling him you
know the Americans are really supplying
Britain and when are you boats it off
the east coast and they're in the
Caribbean they see these huge convoys
the cities aren't even blocked out we
can see the neon lights of Miami or
Newark or New York and if we could just
declare war on them even though we only
have 10 or 12 you boats we could get 50
or 60 and we could wipe out the u.s.
Merchant Marine and that waste our
Britain into submission because we can't
touch these boats because we're not
officially at war and that had an undue
influence on Hitler and was explains the
inexplicable why after Pearl Harbor he
declared war the United States it looked
like for a minute just as in the case of
the early failures of the US strategic
bombing campaign that the axis had the
edge so between January of 1942 in June
of 1942 there was what they called a
second happy time a period in which you
boats had the technological edge they
had the strategic edge and the United
States really didn't listen to the
British about the importance of convoy
or didn't really know how sophisticated
the British had become with radar and
sonar and then in their own turn they
really didn't understand how to use
submarines even though they had created
a brilliantly designed Gado class which
will be followed by the bellow and Tinch
class submarines which were the best in
the world by 1944 but we didn't really
know how to use them against Japan much
less put them in the Mediterranean with
the British to attack Italian shipping
but in this period
what the germans call the second happy
time they at for a brief moment
destroyed about fifty percent of all of
the commerce and trade that going into
the the british isles and that was an
unsustainable rate and it looked like
the u-boat camp campaign was going to be
successful but remember world war two as
we said earlier is a story of challenge
counter challenge response counter
response and so when the allies looked
at this unsustainable loss they came up
with a lot of solutions one was they
improved radar they improved sonar they
got their hands on german naval codes
through the so called ultra project so
they were able to predict where the
germans would be they would be able to
predict their tactics because they were
reading their codes of attack most
importantly they developed a merchant
marine building campaign and a so called
liberty and freedom ship where they were
able to produce wonderful 10,000
displacement tunned merchant ships at
the rate of about once every one every
three days in the oakland and seattle
shipyards and so we sort of out built
the Germans effort to destroy what we
had in the Merchant Marines and even at
the the greatest period of German
success in destroying Allied shipping we
were creating more tonnage of Merchant
Marine than they were at riding a second
thing that was going on though was when
Germany decided that it battleship fleet
was not obtaining results it sent the
Bismarck out in 1941 and it sent the
Tirpitz out and some of its accompanying
battle cruisers without air supremacy or
even air superiority and what happened
was by May 1941
aircraft carriers were instrumental in
sinking the Bismarck
and the Tirpitz was relegated up to the
fjords and scandinavian never played a
substantial role so there was a reminder
to Hitler that even though you have
created the best battleships in the
world there weren't enough of them and
they weren't were not aircraft carriers
that could supply air protection and you
did not coordinate your air on the
continent to protect these ships at sea
and so we we're in a period of
revolutionary activity in 1941 a couple
of other examples when the war broke out
the United States lost eight ships that
we either sunk are submerged on
battleship roll in Pearl Harbor but
these were mostly antiquated ships they
were slow and the Japanese had not found
our three carriers so as dramatic and as
Grievous those wounds were on December
7th through two raids and they were
accomplished only by the use of six
Japanese carriers they attacked a
fossilized or ossified asset not only
were battleships not the wave of the
future but we had new and much better
battleships and much faster on order and
so there were indications that the
battleship already was obsolete another
good example is on December later
December 8th and in the subsequent week
the British sent their pride of their
fleet a battleship and the battleship
Cruiser repulse into Singapore as if
they're magnificent 14 and 15 inch guns
would so impress the Japanese that they
might think twice about invading
Singapore and in fact over 80 Japanese
bombers from Indochina basis destroyed
both of those capital ships and we
affirmed the lesson learned at Pearl
Harbor and learned in the Atlantic that
a battleship or a battle cruiser without
air superiority is almost helpless and
that huge investment is wasted
is a reminder that you would have been
better to build an aircraft carrier or a
destroyer and by by that suggestion of a
story I mean three or four hundred
destroyers rather than ten or twelve
battleships then invest in these sort of
dinosaurs of the sea if you look at the
strategy then of naval fighting in World
War two it's pretty easy to understand
and it boils down to Germany thinks it's
going to use its Navy to blockade
Britain and starve it out and then
eliminate after June of 1940 the only
enemy that's left remember all of Europe
that present-day EU is under occupation
Soviet Union has not been invaded yet
it's United States as isolationist is
not participating in the war there's
only Britain the air war the so-called
blitz has failed to bring Britain to its
knees the surface campaign of using the
Bismarck or the graph C or the Prinz
Eugen to go out and get into a middle of
a convoy has failed the ships have
either been sunk or they're confined to
their ports the u-boat campaign looks
like it for a while it might work and
then British technology and know-how is
has nullify it
a German camera aboard a u-boat records
an attack
[Music]
the Nazi crew is tense as they come to
the surface for another shot
straight from the target
[Music]
an American destroyer speeds in to
attack the enemy hears and rigs for
diving down into the depths to try to
escape the oncoming fighting ship
[Music]
depth charges are dropped in a deadly
pattern
[Music]
the Nazi is forced to the surface
immediately a torrent of gunfire is
turned on the [ __ ] stop it is doomed
the destroyer sends a rescue boat for
survivors and so ends a camera thrill
and its aftermath and so what's left as
far as the German Navy and the answer is
not much at all after 1943 the u-boats
are pretty much impotent they're being
destroyed at a faster rate than they're
being produced there is no longer a
German surface fleet and Germany's great
hope in the Italian fleet and the
Mediterranean has sort of been dashed
and remember the Italians after the
destruction of free France that is in
June of 1940 the wonderful French fleet
the third large fourth largest fleet in
the world has now been neutralized it's
confined to ports in North Africa the
British are forced to destroy it and for
a brief moment Mussolini has six
battleships 20 cruisers he has naval
superiority inside the Mediterranean
Hitler is suggesting to him if you just
take Malta we took Crete we can then go
into Gibraltar maybe we can flip franco
and help the Spanish help us then we can
unleash leash Rommel he might get to the
Egyptian border and go all the way to
Suez and we would have the Mediterranean
as a as an access lake and we could cut
off all importation of strategic
materials from the Middle East and
elsewhere through the Suez Canal to
Britain the problem of course is that
Italy has surface ships and the surface
ships are not like British surface ships
they don't have a night capability to
fire effectively at night they don't
have radar and they don't have cruise
and training and Admirals like the
British do in a series of battles
between nineteen nineteen forty and
forty two the Italian fleet is either
destroyed or confined to its ports at
that point there is no longer an axis
naval war after 1943 if you're a German
Submariner or you're in an Italian
destroyer and you
on the Mediterranean a British ship is
going to sink you or a British baseball
mer is going to destroy you if you're in
the Atlantic after 1943 you are going to
have no success attacking a convoy and
you're probably going to eventually be
sunk at the end of the war about 75% of
the German u-boat fleet which translates
into about 40,000 German sailors are
going to die and yet that was a great
hope of Germany's naval efforts in world
war ii to sum up if we were to look at
world war ii on water around 1944 let's
say around november
there is no naval warfare the British
and American fleets have absolute not
naval superiority but naval supremacy
they can land ships and troops and ports
they can build anywhere they want in
North Africa they can land troops in
Italy and on d-day the Germans can't
even put a credible naval force to stop
some 7,000 ships of various sizes and
sorts or gonna land troops on Normandy
and they're subject to an economic
blockade and that's what Mahon had
originally suggested in his theories of
naval supremacy in other words once you
have control of the water you can affect
the course of fighting on land and
that's what happened in Europe in 1944
there was a little bit more trouble in
the Pacific Theater for a variety of
reasons beloved dead each of us gathered
here today safely sheltered we remember
we remember the graves far away nurses
soldiers children of Pearl Harbor but
remembering is not enough hating is not
enough sacrifices yes no matter what
when the war breaks out Japan had the
third largest Navy in the world but most
importantly it had the second largest
carrier fleet in some ways if you count
all classifications of carriers it was
superior to the British carrier fleet
and more importantly
it its basis in the greater coprocessor
East Asia co-prosperity sphere were much
more conducive to Pacific warfare than
was Pearl Harbor or San Diego or London
in other words at Rabaul or truck or
Singapore or Manila after Japan had
taken these key American and British
bases the Japanese Navy was going to be
very hard to get out because you have
questions of supply and logistics you
had to send an American fleet to save
Australia all the way to go out a canal
or you had to send them beyond Hawaii to
Midway or you had to send them all the
way off the coast of New Guinea to the
Coral Sea and yet the Japanese fleet was
based in these rings of defense in the
Pacific that made their logistic
challenges much easier and so the
question the ultimate question of naval
warfare in the Pacific would be can the
United States destroy these six or seven
fleet carriers and can they destroy the
means of production in Japan so they
can't build more while themselves
creating a vast new carrier fleet and by
1943 the answer is getting very close to
resolution in other words if you count
an escort carrier which is about 7,000
8,000 9,000 tons it's a brilliant idea
of taking a light cruiser haul putting a
flat landing platform on it and putting
60 planes many of them still good but
have been superseded by more advanced
models and you build say a hundred of
them and then you have light carriers of
15 to 20,000 tons and you can carry
maybe 70 or 80 planes and then you have
fleet carriers of 30,000 tons and they
can hold maybe a hundred planes and you
build a hundred and forty five of these
carriers and each of them has a range of
about 500 mile
then you can achieve naval superiority
at the same time you're unleashing a
submarine campaign against Japanese
commerce you're you're trying to bomb
Japan from February of 1945 and
therefore you're gonna stop the ability
of the Japanese to build carrier they
only build about six five or six fleet
carriers from World War two why we build
27 and they hardly build any light or
escort carriers as well so the story is
that the United States starts World War
two with losing its battleship fleet at
Pearl Harbor and it's kind of privately
relieved they think if those ships had
been at sea they were slow they were
World War one vintage we could have lost
fifteen sixteen thousand trained sailors
thank God they were here and more
importantly we have a new class of
battleship about ten or twelve so-called
fast battleship the North Dakota and
eventually the Maryland the California
but eventually we're going to have these
four battleships of the iowa-class and
the result is instead of going
twenty-two knots or 23 knots they're
gonna go 30 knots or 35 knots they're
all going to have 16-inch guns they're
gonna have a high precision high caliber
barrel so that they can shoot a 16 inch
projectile about 22 miles and they can
do so with more accuracy than Japanese
battleship and most importantly we're
going to use these battleships in an
innovative way that had not been true of
Europe or even the Japanese in other
words we're going to get to Japan by
island hopping we're going to go through
two routes we're going to go through New
Guinea to the Philippines under
MacArthur and the army largely army
divisions and then Nimitz and the
Marines will go to truck they're going
to go to paly lu they're going to go to
Iwo Jima Okinawa the Mariana Islands and
as they do so we're going to use these
battleships to pull up alongside the
Islands and use these enormous Li lethal
barrels not against other battleship but
to pound Japanese installations on the
island and we have with the resurrected
battleships four of them that were lost
at Pearl Harbor and the twelve that we
that builder in the war we're going to
have sixteen battleships about forty
five heavy cruisers that have 8-inch
guns another twenty or thirty light
cruisers that have six-inch guns and
we're going to build the largest number
of destroyers in the world almost four
hundred of them with three and four inch
guns and the result will be each time we
target an island not only will Japanese
submarines not be able to get within the
rings of protections of the destroyers
light cruisers cruisers battleship
carriers but hand in glove with the
carriers the battleships will pound the
coral installations and reinforced
concrete bunkers of Japanese and the
carriers will sit there and pound them
with constant air sorties again
predicated on the idea of achieving
naval superiority and destroying the
Japanese fleet
the Japanese Nestle is shot up by the
planes that dive with blazing guns
how then did the United States and
Britain achieve naval superiority in the
Pacific and the answer is multifold the
first thing to remember is that as we
discussed earlier the naval war against
the Germans and the Italians is
essentially over in mid-1943
Italy is knocked out of the war by all
practice for all practical purposes in
June and July of 1943 and its fleet is
confined to its harbors Germany to the
degree it has a surface fleet it's
either in hiding or it's damaged it's in
drydock its u-boat fleet while they're
still you boats two or three hundred
active they're isolated their codes have
been broken and technologically they
have lost the race to evade British
detection or American detection what
that meant in the Pacific was that each
time a British shipyard or an American
shipyard built a transport ship or build
a submarine or a destroyer or cruiser or
battleship or a carrier there was no
longer a European first idea Pacific
second it was we've kind of bifurcated
our assets so tanks artillery army
divisions they tend to go to Europe most
of the strategic bombers go to Europe
but now we're free because there's not
really a worry about an Italian and
German Navy to shift all of our assets
literally carriers and battleships
within in the American case to the
Pacific and that was coupled with an
enormous increase in American
shipbuilding at the Kaiser shipyards in
Richmond California the SS Benjamin
Warner last Liberty ship to be built on
the Pacific coast stands ready for
launching
Kaiser shipyards will now manufacture
the new larger and faster victory ships
for the Allies the SS Benjamin Warner
takes its place in the great fleet of
American built merchant vessels and so
we're flooding the Pacific with American
merchant ships and they are being
escorted by three to four hundred
destroyers and we have a fleet of over
200 submarines that are operating out of
Pearl Harbor and the result of it is
then we're bringing naval assets to the
Pacific from the Atlantic Theater or
when we build new ones we no longer
think we have to divert very many to
Europe so it's pretty much a war of
Japan versus the entire naval potential
of the United States and to a lesser
extent of Great Britain second thing to
remember is that there is a
technological revolution going on and
while a carrier is a static asset in
other words when you build though the
Lexington or the Saratoga or the
enterprise they can't be radically
improved too much because they're
already built in there at sea it's not
like having a battleship once you have a
16-inch gun you're stuck with a 16-inch
gun you can maybe get a different size
powder charge but you're stuck with it
once you have a carrier you're not stuck
with the airplane and what's happening
in between 42 and 45 is that the
Japanese are not investing in pilot
training and they don't have the fuel to
conduct training missions but most
importantly the best fighter in the
world you could argue was the model zero
the Misha beeshees zero which was the
terror of the skies over China and
Southeast Asia in 1939 and 40 superior
to the American Peter teen I nor p40 or
Wildcat but not so true by 1943 so in
1944 so when these new fleet carriers
the essex-class come online they are
better than their Japanese counterparts
in fact they're much better than earlier
carriers as defined by the length of the
deck fire fighting technique speed
reliability but most importantly they
have a different type of airplane now
and we have learned to put and not a
well of a wildcat we have the ability to
put a Hellcat so what does that mean it
means they speed of an American fighter
craft on a aircraft deck is no longer
270 miles but it's nearly four hundred
miles an hour and it's no longer
carrying three or four or five machine
guns but maybe eight and it no longer
has a range of 250 miles but maybe five
or six or 700 miles and it no longer has
a coffin like plane the Devastator
torpedo bomb or they can only go about
100 miles an hour with a torpedo but it
has an avenger torpedo bomber with twice
the range and twice the speed and the
same thing as through the Dauntless dive
bomber versus the new Helldiver dive
bomber so what's happened in this
revolution is suddenly the carriers are
all over the Pacific but they're lethal
armed their air arm has been reinvented
to something that is just so superior
the Japanese that anytime a Japanese
carrier encounters an American carrier
it's going to lose and you can see it in
the progression of naval battles so take
after Pearl Harbor in the first six
months when the Japanese have superior
planes and they have six carriers and we
only have three that are operable for
the first six months the kill ratio off
Singapore if you count Pearl Harbor or
battles in the Java Sea or on the Indian
Ocean it's about 20 Japanese the
Japanese kill about 20 Allied sailors to
every one they lose and in terms of
tonnage it's about thirty to one and
then something happens Americans start
to produce more planes better pilots and
they have better commanders so for all
of the vaunted reputation of Admiral
moto he did not order a third strike at
Pearl Harbor which might have knocked
out the oil production he did not order
his carriers after the Battle of Coral
Sea to pursue and destroy the United
States fleet he split his forces at
Midway the United States Admiralty is
not making those mistakes Japanese
Admirals for supposedly being so
audacious and risk-takers they
understand they have a static fleet and
when they lose a carrier they're not
going to get it replaced easily so they
become very timid by the opposite token
the Americans become very very
aggressive and risk-taking because they
know they're gonna have more and more
carriers to replace any that are lost at
the first battle of the major battle at
Coral Sea in May of 1942 the Americans
get a draw which is pretty incredible
just six months after Pearl Harbor after
all of these devastating losses at sea
that the Allies have incurred they sink
a Japanese carrier and they damage
another Japanese carrier so Kaku and
then they lose the Lexington but the
Yorktown is allowed to excatly home to
Pearl Harbor and then a wonderous thing
happened that's reflective of the the
entire dilemma for the Japanese Imperial
fleet whereas the Yorktown is almost
sunk it goes into Pearl Harbor and then
within 72 hours they literally shut down
the power grid of Honolulu and rebuild
the carrier at least enough to get out
to sea but Japan takes its damaged
carrier and puts it in Yokohama for six
months it doesn't replace the air crews
so you can see that there's subtleties
to naval warfare that we really don't
pay attention to how big is your
maintenance crew how big is your
training crew how good is your
decision-making at the Admiralty level
and the United States is starting to see
that with Halsey and Spruance and Nimitz
and Ernest King at the Chief of Naval
Operations we have a vaunted advantage
the next great battle at Midway we still
only have the enterprise and the Hornet
we somehow get the Yorktown back that
the Japanese are think is sunk meanwhile
the Japanese there are two great fleet
carriers one has lost too many planes at
Coral Sea the other was damaged there
and they're in port so the advantage is
not so great it's now four Japanese
carriers against three American carriers
even though the Japanese have perhaps
better planes more carriers and more
subsidiary ships they cannot take the
island of Midway in a devastating series
of reverses the American fleet will
destroy all four of the Japanese fleet
carriers at Midway and at that point you
can make the argument that Japan no
longer has naval superiority in the
Pacific it doesn't have the Americans
don't have superiority themselves it's
more like parody but in the long term
you can see that the trends will not be
good for the Japanese because we're
training more planes we're going to
eventually send over a hundred thousand
planes think of it a hundred thousand
planes to the Pacific to be based at
bases and on carriers the Japanese in
this timeframe will build about ten
thousand for carrier and land-based
operations and so in 1942 there you're
starting to see a change and then in
five key naval battles in succession in
the fall of 1943 off Guadalcanal in 243
the Americans will essentially even
though they will lose two more carriers
and with the Lexington gone and the
Yorktown gone and the Hornet will be
sunk and the wasp will be sunk four and
the Saratoga will be torpedoed for a
brief moment brief moment the Japanese
are excited that only the enterprise
seems to be out there and it's wounded
what they don't quite understand is as I
said there's 27 Essex carriers are now
going to start to appear but income
recompense for that they have lost a
number of cruisers they have lost a
light carrier they have lost a number of
destroy
and they've lost Guadalcanal as 1943
starts the American submarine fleet
fixes its torpedo problems it gets new
classes of submarines it's allowed to
venture further and further from Pearl
Harbor and you're going to start to see
the effect of these tactics these new
ships and especially new Hellcat
fighters Avengers and Helldiver dive
bombers and in a series of battles in 44
off the Mariana Islands we notice a
great Maryana turkey shoot and then at
Leyte Gulf off the Philippines the
United States Navy will basically
destroy all of the naval air capability
the Japanese Imperial fleet and a series
of submarine attacks and air attacks by
the end of 1944 the Imperial Navy has
rendered combat ineffective now what
does that mean that means while there's
still a few submarines it means that
every time the US Marines and Army
decide to take an island there's not
going to be a Japanese plane appearing
out of the skies to bomb a transport
ship an in Finnish if when Americans
landed
Iwo Jima or Okinawa they're not going to
be straight by Japanese planes and their
only resort will be as we discussed
earlier a desperate attempt to revive a
naval arm or even a narrow arm through
kamikaze but it will mean that the
United States can supply oil munitions
and repair parts anywhere it wants in
the Pacific and it will start - as in
the case of an onion peel away layer
after layer after layer of the Japanese
Empire and it will do so by fighting a
war completely different than what it
fought in Europe and this is really
important to understand the calculus of
world war two we get caught up in this
notion of well we we
70% of our material and our labor to
Europe because Hitler was deemed the
greater threat and then we shorted the
Pacific War and it wasn't that simple as
nobody in the right mind
understood the capabilities of the US
economy at the end of the war in terms
of gross domestic product the United
States is producing more goods and
services than Russia Japan that defunct
Italians the Germans and the British
Empire combined and what that means is
that they are able to conduct two wars
simultaneously through the greater
industrial production of all their
enemies and allies combined and more
importantly they tend to be
complementary rather than antithetical
by that I mean when you build a tank you
you can send some to the Pacific but you
usually send it to Europe when you build
a hundred and five or 155 millimeter
horowitz or gun you send it to Europe if
you have a p-51 or a p-47 or beef 17 you
use it more in Europe same as two of the
b-24 however if you're building
submarines if you're building cruisers
destroyers battleships carriers carrier
craft like the Hellcat fighter or the
courser marine fighter you can direct or
the b-29 heavy bomber you direct all of
that to the Pacific and because Britain
at the same time is fighting in Burma
and trying to protect India and because
of the demise of the Italian and German
fleet Britain is doing the same thing
it's sending its carrier and battleship
fleet to the Pacific and this reaches a
crescendo as I said in earlier 1945
where the Japanese Imperial fleet has
disappeared from the Pacific as large as
it is as formidable as it is it's a it's
a huge vast ocean but by mid 1945 the
American fleet can do what it wants it
can supply it can deploy wherever it
wants and
hope of the Japanese war effort itself
that is the Japanese Imperial fleet the
dream of Admiral Yamamoto is now dashed
and it will be simply a question of
whether the fleet as in the case of the
Air Arm will be so superior to the
Japanese whether it will be it will
preclude a land engagement altogether so
far we've talked about air power and
naval power in terms of redirecting
fighting on the ground up into the air
at sea on the premise that if you were
able to achieve first superiority and
second supremacy then those theaters
could be redirected to the ground that
is you could use ships to attack our
ground forces are to augment or enhance
ground forces or you could do the same
with planes but central that argument is
the ground is where the action is the
ground is where the war will be won or
lost in our next lecture we're going to
see why that is so and why the Allies
were able to defeat Germany and Italy
and Japan on the ground
you